[Music]
in the 1990s to this refugee camp
her family has lived through the highs
and lows of relations between india and
pakistan
but says this time it's different
it's been three days since we have heard
from my sister and her family
i heard rumors that 40 to 50 people have
been killed
we don't know anything even the internet
is shut are they even alive
her husband says they escaped kashmir
when he was tortured and had his fingers
and toes broken by indian forces
occupying their lands
all we want is freedom for god's sake is
there anyone listening
any muslims all over the world the u.n
god will ask them on the day of
judgement
the conflict over kashmir has separated
many families for years
more than 35 000 people live in refugee
camps on the pakistani side of the
divided region
most people in ambour camp are from
indian administered kashmir although
temporary structures have been turned
into concrete homes but almost every
household has family or relatives
still on the other side they fear the
worst as the indian government's
crackdown continues
zara bukhari came here when she was just
over a year old
she went to school in the camp and now
teaches at a college for refugees
one of her brothers was killed before
they moved and her mother says
indian forces have killed other
relatives in their fight for freedom
it's an emotional issue when she talks
about not being able to contact her
extended family
because phone lines and the internet
remains cut off
what if they were burnt alive what if
they were killed we don't know anything
about what's happening in our kashmir
what's happening to our brothers sisters
and children does anyone care
at the girls school in the camp children
discuss politics as parents in most
homes
talk about a free kashmir a few weeks
before the latest escalation
sirath farooq's relatives asked them not
to call anymore
because they fear harassment by indian
security forces
they say if we talk to them they will be
detained so we haven't spoken to them
for many days
we are very worried and we've seen on tv
that people are being persecuted in
kashmir
even the children here know about how
tensions have flared
since constitutional changes by india to
the status of kashmir
kashmiris here say india is holding 12
million of their people hostage
and are calling on pakistani government
leaders to do more
than the usual rhetoric
pakistan administered kashmir